Failed and disgraced former Fox News host
Bill O'Reilly lost his mind over minorities
after the Highland Park shooting on Monday.
You have to see this video clip.
Let me set up what's going on with Bill O'Reilly,
who,
by the way, seems even more unhinged than
I remember him when he was on his Fox News
show.
The governor of Illinois, Pritzker, held a
press conference after the shooting.
And one of the things that Bill O'Reilly took
from that is Democrats and the left only care
about these types of shootings because the
perpetrators aren't minorities.
But when you look at gang violence, drug crime,
violence, etc., it's minorities.
And so Democrats don't want to talk or talk
about it.
Now, the funny thing about this, as we look
at the clip, is in saying this, Bill O'Reilly's
reasoning is completely flawed, and I'll tell
you why in a moment.
But he's sort of admitting the mass shooters
are almost exclusively young white men.
Right.
I mean, he basically saying the demographics
of the gang violence don't interest Democrats
by definition.
He's saying the demographics of the
mass shooters are different and we know that
they are.
It's mostly young white men in the United
States.
Okay.
So here's Bill O'Reilly completely losing
his mind, saying Democrats don't want to deal
with shootings when it's minorities doing
the shooting.
O'Reilly at his most disheveled and unhinged.
You, JB, are not going to stop loans and you
won't stop crime.
Drug crime, drug gangs because they're minority
gangs.
That's why you won't stop them, you phony
you.
Aid an event, this murder in Chicago every
blanking day.
By the way, again.
It was not in Chicago.
They love to do the Chicago thing because
they they believe Chicago puts the image in
your mind again of gang violence or whatever.
This was in a swanky suburb.
You.
Don't be sanctimonious with me.
So.
O'REILLY Having a having a normal one.
This is a real get off my lawn moment.
And I've spoken about this so many times,
preventing individual single shootings when
specific people are being targeted like you
see in gang violence is number one, most importantly,
completely different animal than what we're
talking about with mass shootings in terms
of his causes.
And it's there in terms of solutions and prevention.
And number two, it's it is really difficult
to prevent individual violence, even in some
cases when you eliminate the guns, although
you do sort of dissuade people, you make them
have to maybe use a more personal tool like
a knife or whatever.
It doesn't mean we don't try.
So let's just think it through.
And again, when we talk about deaths at the
hands of guns, we have three categories that
we're concerned with.
And these are
in no particular order.
You have gun suicides.
You have sort of individual gun homicides,
which includes disgruntled spouses.
It includes, you know, hit men.
It includes gang violence, drug deals gone
wrong, that type of thing.
And then you've got your mass shooters.
These are three different things.
The causes are different.
The potential solutions are different.
It's they're just different things.
Consider if a disgruntled, psychopathic ex-spouse
wants to kill his girlfriend and I say his
girlfriend or his ex-wife because it's almost
always a man doing it, it's just the way it
is.
The type of policy we're talking about on
mass shootings is mostly not going to do that.
Now, if you make it really difficult to even
get a handgun, the ex, the disgruntled ex-spouse
will say, well, I'm going to do it with a
knife or I'm going to do it with a baseball
bat or whatever.
It's more it's more personal and up close.
So they may not do it, but it is a different
type of thing when when a gang member member
says, I've been disrespected by this person
and I've now got to get back at them.
You know, limiting rifles so that they end
up with a handgun or even in some cases limiting
had they if they're determined to go after
a particular individual, they're going to
do it to some degree.
Maybe they won't kill them separately.
Here we're talking about mass shootings where
you need certain tools and certain provisions
to dissuade you, make guns harder to get,
or at least you make the deadlier guns harder
to get.
Well, then this particular shooter might have
killed fewer people.
That would be good.
We want zero people killed, but killing one
instead of seven is better.
Injuring one instead of dozens is better.
You make the ammunition really expensive.
Well, maybe he wouldn't have had as many bullets
would have reduced the lethality of it.
You put an age limit on rifles.
Well, he might have been relegated to a handgun.
The number of people he'll kill with a handgun
from a rooftop is probably a lot lower number
than what he was able to do.
It's just different.
And so Bill O'Reilly saying you just don't
want to go after black people who commit crime.
That's what O'Reilly saying.
And it's absurd.
And these are different types of of incidents
and we should deal with all of them.
But the way you reduce gun violence has components
that are very different when it comes to the
way you reduce gang gun.
Violence has elements that are very different
than when we talk about these typical
mass shootings.
And so we don't say one is a bigger or smaller
problem or whatever.
We say we want to deal with multiple problems.
The fact that treating, you know, a damaged
knee is done differently than cancer doesn't
mean we ignore either.
It just means we take different approaches.
That's all that's all that we're saying.
And O'Reilly, I mean, look at this guy completely
out of his gourd, completely out of his gourd
has lost it.
All right.
Let me know your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
so much more.
The David Pakman Show is a community funded
program.
What community?
Well, you you're part of the community.
If you listen to this podcast, if you watch
the show on YouTube or listen on one of our
radio affiliates or even watch on our television
affiliates, free speech TV, underactive dish,
you're part of the community and I would love
for you to support our work by signing up
at join Packman dot com.
It's very cheap.
It comes with great benefits, including commercial
free audio and video streams of the show every
day, five or 6 hours earlier than we publish
the show to everybody, as well as the world
famous bonus show.
Oh, the bonus show where you want to make
money.
Everybody else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad.
Well, call it what it is, but it's an extra
show every single day just for our members.
You can sign up at join Pacman dot com.
You can use the coupon code if you want.
Don't feel obligated, but it's available.
Big voting 22 all one word, all lowercase,
big voting 22 and you'll get a beautiful discount